you nickname me certainly many years ago
you came on the show and you said I have
I said you were talking my nicknames and
I said what would my nickname be and you
said Kohner boner a new one for you now
oh you have a new one okay because I
thought that was fantastic
yeah what's the new one I think you need
to upgrade yes thank you so in light of
this movie and the Statesmen right
statesmen want to offer you a new name a
new name I will take any nickname I've
been Coco for a while and it's done
nothing for me so I'm I'm ready to move
on yeah this one might help you a little
bit um it's a Perl Wow he chose this
moment perfectly he was in line thinking
if I get in there and Halle Berry search
the table I'm gonna wait til she sings
something real Borton how I look and the
Darth Vader helmet goes right back on
again
I want to hear my friends
I'll take care you don't want your mind
okay so your new name is Aperol spritz
what appro appro spritz that well I
brought a picture of it shows I don't
know what an apple spritz is like that
your hair used to be much wetter they
used to be redder yeah that's why I came
up with that okay a pro spritz yeah you
know what dudes really feared when April
spritz comes to town Chani you had
another idea this is just another option
yeah
fireballs what's that fireball I can't
hear anything
you